today we're all about the puffins and
how something quite futuristic could
protect this most Charming of seabirds
[Music]
welcome to the climate show with me Tom
Heap in a moment I'm going to be going
out in this boat for our film on how the
latest tech is helping nature also on
the program angry walkouts and damning
verdicts the international climate
Minister quits with a vicious swipe at
Rishi sunak saying on environment you
are prime minister are simply
uninterested I speak to the chief
executive of the UK climate Watchdog as
it delivers a withering report on the
government's performance and we'll be at
the Glastonbury of farming as nature
friendly practices hit the mainstream
I'm on my way to the Isle of May and
this place has been a thriving seabird
Colony for centuries but now there's a
new arrival that's helping protect
puffins artificial intelligence
I'm on the way to the Isle of May one of
the most important Puffin colonies in
British Waters
29 miles from Edinburgh in the mouth of
the first fourth it's home to 46 000
breeding pairs of puffins plenty of
other seabirds and four people to study
them
so you might think it's an unlikely
Frontier for artificial intelligence
I could sit here for hours watching this
show
I know it's not the right term but I
feel like I'm in the midst of a swarm of
puffins and they're so comic they're not
really the most graceful of birds but
they've got this kind of urgency oh I've
got to be somewhere quickly I'm flapping
really hard
yeah
but they are so charismatic
but being lovable doesn't help if you
haven't got enough food in recent years
sand deals the very thing you can see
hanging from these puffins beaks have
become commercially fished and used in
animal feed
and sudden swings in Sea temperature
exaggerated by climate change can
interrupt Food Supplies
they spend eight months at Sea returning
to breed on land in Spring rearing their
chicks in Burrows
and this time ashore is the short window
for studying them with so many birds to
keep track of scientists need extra eyes
they are tracking what the puffins are
doing on a day-to-day basis which sounds
like a very straightforward thing but
actually before we had the cameras here
David and his team would be going around
with their clipboard and doing that by
hand puffins are fantastic Birds aren't
they you know everyone loves a puffin
everyone wants to see a puffin Warden
David has now got robot work colleagues
what are these AI cameras going to be
able to do that experience guys like you
can't well it's got the time hasn't it
it's got 24 hour coverage of these
Puffin colonies of course we're
dedicated to these islands but we can't
give it all to the puffins we've got a
lot of seabirds to protect we've got
visitors coming on dearly so this has
just given us a good snapshot into the
lives of the puffins you're not worried
that this artificial intelligence might
put your intelligence out of business
someone said you'll be working from an
office a series of cameras no not it's
all these are here to benefit and help
us can it track individuals would you be
able to say you know here's Nigel or
Janet back from the sea I mean would it
be able to say you should do that so
that is the aim and that's what is this
AI with with the puffins is hoping to
Shore that we can actually do facial
necklace on every individual Puffin
within the the monitoring site and of
course that gives us some great data and
we can actually find out sort of you
know what's going on with these birds
you know and then on a wider scale
what's going on the north side two
cameras have been watching Puffin since
they arrived in April and are learning
how to identify it and differentiate
between birds and flowers the white
flowers are the same with the chest of
the Puffin so it got a bit confused but
that's what AI doesn't learn so we put
it through the AI process again and to
say here's a training footage that says
flubers this is a puffin and then it
knows not to count flowers and little
counter patterns
Energy company SSE are involved in the
project because their wind turbines can
harm seabirds a greater understanding of
their behavior could reduce this
conflict and artificial intelligence
could help to regenerate nature too as
well as conservid artificial
intelligence isn't just working on the
small scale looking at individual birds
it's also taking a much bigger picture
this tool uses satellites and artificial
intelligence to predict which areas
around the world will be best suited for
regeneration projects like tree planting
or grassland restoration the machine
learns from data about one bit of land
that has already been mapped and studied
and then applies what it knows to other
bits of land with similar
characteristics over time it will become
more and more accurate what you're
seeing on the screen is degradation so
this is basically showing that this area
is is highly sort of degraded red is bad
is it yeah red red is bad and what we
can calculate effectively is if this
area were to be regenerated through
sustainable grazing management
techniques how much carbon can actually
be sequestered and that's essentially
where our tools bring in the the sort of
the machine learning and the artificial
intelligence to be able to identify that
potential now what gets us super excited
is that the more projects that we get to
regenerate the more kind of real world
data that we get that then can feed back
in and to train those sort of models
over time
in order to fight climate change and
biodiversity loss the UN says the world
needs to spend eight trillion dollars on
nature in the next 30 Years using data
like this can reassure investors that
their money is going into the right
project in the right places making them
more likely to invest
there is still suspicion around
artificial intelligence in general but
could Ai and nature be a natural fit the
scale of the challenge that we're facing
is is enormous
um and you we need to use technology we
need to use sort of artificial
intelligence everything that we have at
our disposal in order to be able to sort
of deliver and and tackle that sort of
planetary problem while some see
artificial intelligence as a threat to
humanity could it emerge as Nature's
savior
anguish over the nature crisis and the
government's environment record blew up
in politics this week as the climate
Minister and international Envoy Zach
Goldsmith resigned from the cabinet it
came after he was criticized by The
Commons privileges Committee in its
report on Boris Johnson but his
resignation letter makes clear that he
stood down because of anger over the
government's environment policies and it
is a furious dispatch here are just some
of the pointed phrases
the UK has visibly stepped off the world
stage and withdrawn our leadership on
climate and nature
then
this government's apathy in the face of
the greatest challenge we have faced
makes continuing in my current role
untenable
and most pointedly for Rishi sunak the
problem is not that the government is
hostile to the environment it is that
you our prime minister are simply
uninterested
well to get some reaction to that here
are the thoughts of our energy and
climate correspondent Hannah Thomas
Peter who was at an event that Zach
Goldsmith was expected to attend
it's not so much I suppose the
resignation of Lord Goldsmith that is
surprising he's obviously a man under a
degree of political pressure but the
manner of his resignation the language
he used is really quite striking full of
contempt and dismay he says that the
prime minister is uninterested in
environmental issues personally unmoved
now that kind of language the contempt
involved in it really adds to this drum
beat for me of criticism of this
government that it has started to
de-prioritize climate change as an issue
by approving new oil and gas licenses
for example we've had that recent
criticism from the climate change
committee that the government is way off
track in meeting its Net Zero targets
and there has been additional criticism
that actually what's happening is the
government has made a political choice
not to prioritize climate change not to
be seen to be preaching on this issue or
meddling with people's lives too much
when it comes to things like electric
vehicles or heat pumps and I suppose
there's a widening Gap now and Zach
Goldsmith's language and resignation
only adds to that sense between the
grand promises that were made under
Boris Johnson and this government's
actual plans to deliver them
Lord Goldsmith's scathing resignation
comes in the same week as the annual
progress report from the government's
climate Watchdog and it wasn't pretty it
said it was markedly less confident than
a year ago that the UK would reach its
legally binding emissions reduction
targets
across a mammoth 451 Pages the climate
change committee found that the
government has lost its Global
Leadership on the climate and
backtracked on fossil fuel commitments
with a tranche of new coal oil and gas
approvals been too slow to react to
Green investment in the U.S and the EU
creating a strong pull for green
investment away from the UK has no
coherent program to encourage people to
change to lower carbon behaviors has no
clear policy to decarbonize heavy
Industries
insulated fewer homes than the year
before despite higher energy costs and
is well off track on its Target for heat
pump installations with Britain sitting
bottom of the pile per capita across the
whole of Europe
and the chief executive of the climate
change committee joins me now that's
Chris Stark Chris just a few weeks ago
we had Grant chaps on the program we
talked about this government having an
unrivaled record of decarbonizing you're
painting a very different picture we are
painting a different picture I think we
can look back and see quite a strong
record of progress and it's been very
notable that ministers have been doing a
lot of retrospection recently about how
good things have been how many targets
have been met that's not really what the
support's about so we've been looking
out to 2030 and Beyond 2030s you might
recall the dates that we set these very
ambitious targets for just 18 months ago
in Glasgow at the climate Summit just
seven years away now
and we think if you look outside of the
areas where the government has been
putting you know real effort into it if
you look at the outside of the power
sector in particular
good story and power of course but
outside of the power sector we think we
need a quadrupling of the progress that
we see in other parts of the economy to
hit that 2030 goal so bright past
slightly dismal future at the moment
well no I think dismal is probably not
the right word I'm just very worried
about that 2030 goal and it's not just
2030 it takes you one of course beyond
that and we just don't see in this very
detailed program now that we've got from
the government the kind of ambition that
would take us to those 2030 goals you
yourself say we are going to need some
fossil fuels in the mix to take a 20 30
and Beyond I mean Grant chaps makes a
point that it's better that they come
from here
so maybe we ought to allow a bit more
new drilling what do you make of that I
mean what's been really striking in the
last year is that we've got a set of
notionally ministers notionally working
in climate change who seem to have been
talking more about oil and gas than
anything else you definitely see that
with grand chaps with grim Stewart no
doubt there is room for some mixed oil
and gas production particularly gas you
know I can accept the arguments that in
the in the middle of an energy crisis
like this if there is some way to
extract more gas that would be useful
although it just goes on to the
international market it does and that's
the challenge Julie so we're not sure of
oil
um gas is definitely more of a challenge
but we don't have any way of mandating
that it comes to the UK it's short of
nationalizing those those companies and
I'm not aware that that's a grand Chap's
policy so I I think we need to focus on
the real challenging which is reducing
our demand for the stuff in the first
place
so does all this mean you're hoping for
a labor win in the next general election
I I you will never get that from me I
mean I'm very interested to see what
happens at the next general election but
I don't think we need a change of
government to see a change in plan
there's a point nesting behind this
I get the feeling that a lot of people
are looking now to the next general
election as the point where we might
change the story on climate that's just
too late so you know if we have to wait
another year without progress in some of
these critical issues we are definitely
going to miss that 2030 goal
um seven years isn't is you know simply
Too Short a period to have another
wasted year just a broader one it seems
to me that we've moved from a position
18 months ago around the time of the
Glasgow cop where within politics people
were competing to do more on climate
with almost
the reverse of that what would labor
backing away from their firm investment
plans as you say the government
basically saying very little on climate
do you read that in relative depressing
momentum in the wrong direction I I'm
afraid I think I do one of the things
I've done this week is go back to the
work that we produced around the time of
cop26 and you can tell from the papers
we were producing the reports we're
producing it was just more enthusiasm
for everything and it does feel like
that now um I've been talking about the
present situation is it but you've got
this kind of really odd situation you've
got this massive program of work now
happening in government massive you know
across the whole government but it is an
exercise collectively in pushing pieces
of string unless there's someone at the
top pulling that string taut and it
feels like that's absent though and I
you know at that discussion of this
opportunity of getting to Net Zero has
really exited the scene I think that's
the thing that we need to see back when
it comes to climbers do you miss Boris
Johnson
uh there are many bits with Boris
Johnson's time that I do not miss uh I
certainly do uh miss the the strong
rhetorical support that he provided for
an s0
um you don't need Boris Johnson for that
though yeah any leader of any government
and it's not just in this country should
feel able to talk about NetZero in those
terms that it seems to me is something
you could put right very quickly and but
it matters that kind of rhetoric from
the top matters as well and I'm sure the
policies matter but that kind of
enthusiasm in that direction matters
yeah something I'm asked a lot about and
often is you know what structure in
government could you create that would
make it more likely they'll deliver
and the answer I quite often give is
well you can invent these things but it
only works when you know that the person
at the top wants it and that's you know
generally what was happening during the
Boris Johnson you know I don't imagine
that Boris Johnson was looking over
again charts of progress
um and delivery plans but you need
someone who's willing to talk about it
and and then the civil servants and the
people working on these issues know
where they stand on it and so does you
know people are in the cabinet table
they know what to do and you know just a
bit of that you know clear support
enthusiastic support would help I think
at the moment I saw a report out this
week saying China looked like it was
going to reach some of its goals in
terms of clean energy generation five
years early I mean we seem to be in a
world where China is now showing the
leadership and we're not it's kind of
embarrassing we reflect on just that
very thing in our report now in the last
12 months lots of things have happened
in the world obviously the Ukrainian
crisis is driving a lot of the story on
claim at the moment we in this country
also had the conservative party
leadership election in that time and I
feel a bit British politics looked
inwards rather than outwards over that
period the US did the inflation
reduction act massive step forward on
climate policy lots of debate about
whether it will work or not but they did
it the EU response to that is also
massive if you look to China they are
putting more Renewables in the ground
than ever before it is by some distance
the bit of the world that's doing the
most investment in Renewables now we
haven't really noticed any of that and I
think we imagine sometimes that we're
not existing in a world that is
interconnected with these things there
is a real risk that will fall behind on
this and that the pace of change in this
country will be slower than those other
places so for climate optimism we have
to look beyond our own Shores I agree so
I think we need to be part of that
Global community on climate and that
means trying to follow when you see
these big steps forward thanks very much
Chris time for a break now and when we
come back we'll be at the Glastonbury of
farming looking at how you can still
grow a lot of food whilst looking after
nature too
welcome back to the show now things have
cooled off a little bit here but over a
hundred million North Americans are
living with dangerous heat and unhealthy
air quality
major cities like Chicago Milwaukee
Detroit Toronto and Pittsburgh were once
again shrouded by thick Wildfire smoke
with authorities urging people to stay
inside and limit their exposure his
Sky's U.S correspondent Mark Stone
well when the bad air first hit at the
stars of the month here in Washington DC
and across large parts of this part of
the United States and Canada too I don't
think many of us realized that it would
be an enduring thing that it seems it is
DC these past few days has been bad with
the air quality officially deemed
unhealthy I was in Chicago midweek where
the iconic Lakeside skyline of
skyscrapers was obscured by the smog New
York Pittsburgh Detroit Philadelphia
Toronto
Ottawa Montreal and many places in
between have all been shrouded in
Canadian Wildfire smoke in America alone
this week a third of the population has
been subjected to air quality alerts
firefighters from Canada and America are
in rural parts of Canada right now
trying to control the fires but experts
say they are unlikely to be put out
until the summer is over have a look at
this NASA imagery it shows the smoke
that is crossing the Atlantic now too
towards Europe
and then there's the heat in the
American South record-breaking
temperatures in Texas 80 million
Americans under heat alerts scientists
are examining unusual behavior by the
jet stream of winds five to seven miles
above the Earth's surface they're
debating whether climate change is
disrupting the jet stream's flow meaning
that certain regions are subjected to
more lengthy hot periods because of high
pressure systems which are being trapped
in Canada that's making the fires worse
elsewhere it's just making it unbearably
hot the concern is that as well as
heating the oceans climate change is
changing the behavior of other weather
phenomena like the jet stream changing
our weather patterns making the weather
more and more extreme and as you can see
here in Washington it's having an impact
far from where those weather events are
hitting
also in the news this week the UK is
closer to having a coal-free electricity
grid after the National Grid confirmed
that two coal-fide units were being
decommissioned and wouldn't be available
as backup this winter the grid says it
expects the UK to have sufficient
capacity but one coal unit remains if
needed
and a few weeks ago we brought you the
story of the Welsh coal mine that has
continued to extract hundreds of
thousands of tons of coal despite its
permission to operate expiring last year
the operators fosifran in merthyr
tydville were recently served an
enforcement notice that was supposed to
take effect on Tuesday giving them 28
days to stop mining but the company
lodged a last-minute appeal possibly
delaying enforcement action for many
months more
we're very much in the festival season
it was Glastonbury last week and this
week a little bit smaller something
that's become known as the Glastonbury
of nature friendly farming it's called
Groundswell and Dairy Farmer Sophie
Gregory showed us around
[Music]
hello I'm Sophie Gregory organic Dairy
Farmer from Dorset Devon border we milk
um 360 cows and today I'm here at
Groundswell and I've been here for two
days and it's a Redemptive Festival
Redemptive farming is a way of looking
at our business in an environmental
social and sustainable way so that we
can leave the farm in a better State for
the future
foreign
[Music]
ER we have quite a lot of farming Avenue
which is bedding from the winter where
the cows have been in and it's a mixture
of straw and cow poo and it's a really
essential nutrients to add back to the
fields it's a bit like composting in
your garden letting it rot down and it
becomes even more nutrients dense and so
we put them in windrows like this and
then the composter turns it through and
you do this about three times and then
you add that back to the fields
[Music]
oh
so this is the UK's first and as far as
I'm aware only fully licensed mobile
multi-species red meat slaughterhouse
which is a bit of a main floor it's
allowed to kill
bollocks or cattle sheep and pigs uh and
and that's something which can be done
regionally which saves any of its
livestock having to travel for great
distances but a lot of the time they
have to do yeah and that's what comes
into regenerative doesn't it because the
welfare of an animal even up to its
death is so important
[Music]
this here
um it's actually called a plate meter
and we always call it the spaceship too
it's a way of measuring grass so we
would walk along in a field there's not
much grass here but we would walk along
in a field and it measures the amount of
grass in that field it enables us to
make clear feeding plans for our cows so
we know exactly what's in a field how
much of the field we need and then we
can see actually where we're improving
where we're not improving and the
implementation of things like mob
grazing how that's improving
regenerative farming has made farming
sexy and exciting again it's been good
for youngsters who might not have
considered a career in farming to get
into the industry that traditional view
of it being an old man in a field with a
piece of straw in his mouth I think it's
now if you look at the demographic here
it's mixed male female from totally
different environments all wanting to
get involved in agriculture and where
their food's from
[Music]
well that's it for now remember you can
catch up on all your environment and
climate news on the Sky News website and
app or by scanning the QR code that is
on your screen right now we'll be back
next week and I'll be catching the bus
foreign
[Music]